(guitar playing)
- Oh my God when Kylo Ren--
- That was crazy.
- Hey, hey spoilers, spoilers.
- Sorry.
- Who do you think Rays parents are?
- Okay so I have a
(talks over each other).
- Digimon are the champions.
- But I'm horny.
- Well it's winter.
- Should we go?
- No, you stay.
- I'm bored.
- I'm hungry.
- This joke sucks.
- Oh my God.
Oh gee that's...
They're real carrots.
- Oh my God.
- Again, again.
Oh, Jesus.
- No, this relationship is broken.
- We really should go.
- No you will stay and sing.
- What?
(gun shot)
- Holy shit, ouch.
- No.
Gross.
Fine.
- Did you just say a dude?
What?
I want a divorce.
- Please welcome to the
1989 world tour stage,
my very best friends,
Ashly Perez, Quinta Brunson
and Ella Mielniczenko
- Don't hit me Eugene.
- [Eugene] Sorry.
- Don't worry about it.
- Oh sorry ass carrots all over you.
Oh another one.